ce soir alors aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler de l'hyper connexion et je vais
aussi vous montrer qu'être moins
connectés à internet va vous apporter du
bien-être
on va commencer par un petit jeu vous
allez tous sortir vos téléphones
portables les mettre dans vos mains et
les éteindre
à lévis sa reine les mettre en mode
avion juge de couper la 4g vous les et à
nier totalement la baisse passée 1 je
t'ai pas il ya quelques années je suis
parti faire un voyage en asie et pendant
plusieurs mois je suis je me suis rendu
dans des régions très reculées suis allé
au nord du laos en inde dans les vallées
de l'himalaya et dans le désert de gobi
en mongolie et tous ces endroits où un
point commun alors bien sûr ce sont des
endroits magnifiques
d'ailleurs je vous conseille vraiment
d'y aller mais surtout tous ces endroits
sont totalement déconnectés d'internet
les populations qui vivent n'ont pas
accès à internet alors ça va en occident
on se dit que c'est impensable de vivre
sans internet et l'a déjà vous êtes
déconnecté depuis une minute et je sais
que certains dans la salle se sont pas
très très bien mais il faut savoir que
l'eau est nu la dernière nous a montré
que 53 % de la population mondiale vit
totalement déconnecté elle n'a aucun
accès à internet alors plus la moitié du
monde vit sans internet
nous on a vécu au final sans internet
pendant des milliers d'années donc vous
rendez bien compte que est déconnecté le
temps de l'intervention
c'est pas si grave aujourd'hui on a
totalement changé nos priorités
on recherche de la wii si on cherche une
prise pour recharger sa batterie plutôt
que de chercher de l'aventuré ou des
nouvelles expériences
on va faire un petit test ici le verlan
si vous avez déjà regardé notre
téléphone en pleine nuit pendant votre
sommeil
mais nadal est là pas mal lever la main
maintenant si la première chose que vous
faites le matin
si vous connecter à votre smartphone ah
ouais l'aïe a quasiment tout le monde ok
elle avait des questions lever la main
si vous avez l'impression que votre
téléphone vibre dans votre poche alors
qu'il n'y est pas bon si vous avez levé
trois fois la main va falloir songer à
se déconnecter un peu plus aujourd'hui
les réseaux sociaux nous rendent
addiction certains passent plus de deux
à trois heures par jour sur les réseaux
sociaux et en fait c'est un système
biologique qui fait qu on a toujours
envie de revenir sur ces réseaux sociaux
mais parfois on avait la vie des autres
ça nous donne envie mais parfois ça nous
déprime et une étude récente menée par
les chercheurs de l'université de
pittsburgh a montré que ceux qui
utilisent trop intensément les réseaux
sociaux on devait abus cette fois plus
de chances de faire une dépression que
ceux qui l'utilisent que de temps en
temps
et puis internet a envahi nos vies
professionnelles
aujourd'hui un cadre de recevoir jusqu'à
80 ml par jour et va envoyer 33 c'est
une sorte d'infobésité qui va créer un
stress et une surcharge informationnelle
chez les salariés un cadre va passer
plus de cinq heures par jour à traiter
ses mails cinq heures par jour c'est
énorme c'est quasiment 30% de sa journée
éveillé et puis il ya le fameux mythe du
multi tasking on pense qu'on peut faire
deux choses à la fois
alors essayez vous avez pas le faire
essayez d'envoyer un e-mail et de
téléphoner en même temps vous allez voir
que vous allez faire soient les fautes
dans votre email
soit vous n'allez pas réussir à saisir
toutes les informations importantes de
vos interlocuteurs
alors si on combine cette addiction
réseaux sociaux avec les problèmes ce
que la technologie crée un entreprise
ça peut nous donner des journées hyper
connectés je prends un exemple je me
lève le matin première chose que je fais
je me connecte sur mon smartphone
j'entre dans la douche
bon là on a de la chance c'est encore le
dernier endroit on n'est pas connecté
mais avec les nouveaux téléphones
portables waterproof
on peut se demander pour combien de
temps encore je prends le métro je suis
connecté
j'arrive au travail je me connecte 7h 8h
9h en face d'un ordinateur ou sur mon
téléphone portable je sors du travail je
suis connecté
je rentre chez moi et après le vide et
je regarde des séries sur netflix par
exemple et je suis encore connectés et
au final s'en rendre compte
j'ai passé 90 % de ma journée totalement
connecté donc si vous imaginez à
l'échelle d'une vie si on vit comme ça
toute ma vie
on va passer notre vie au final
connectés alors cette interconnexion à
créer des problèmes
ça va créer des prêtres de concentration
ça va nuire à notre attention cela crée
des problèmes de créativité mais ça va
surtout augmenter notre niveau de stress
l'étude menée l'année dernière par le
cnrs a montré que 59 % des français
considèrent que les technologies rendre
leur vie professionnelle beaucoup plus
stressante
en effet cela crée des excès de
sollicitations cela les fait travailler
dans l'urgence et la frontière entre la
vie professionnelle et la vie privée est
de plus en plus floue conséquence un
cerveau en chercher en surcharge et une
augmentation du stress
cela peut même aller vers des cas plus
graves de burn out et de dépression le
ms nous indiquait qu'en 2030 la
dépression serait l'une des principales
maladies causant de l'invs a dit
l'invalidité
excusez moi dans le monde et puis ça
pleut encore donné les choses folles
comme ces personnes qui regardent une
course de vélo
si vous voyez bien tourner est avec son
ordinaire
son téléphone portable sauf cette petite
grand mère qui elle encore le temps de
regarder
là on part aux états unis où on a créé
des trottoirs spéciaux pour les gens qui
se connecte sur leur smartphone en
marchant en fait le but c'est vraiment
d'éviter qu'il se rentrent dedans
et là c'est le même système en chine aux
pays bas on a carrément mis des lampes
led avant les passages cloutés pour
éviter que les personnes qui marchent
avec leur téléphone portable comme ça se
fasse écraser par les voitures vous
rendez compte
dans quel monde on part mais
heureusement il n'y a pas que des
problèmes puisqu'ils également des
solutions et je voulais présenter
maintenant on veut notamment n'y pas
connecté mais il existe des solutions
pour se déconnecter pour mieux se
connecter et faire descendre notre
niveau de stress alors la digital detox
c'est la première des solutions de
digital detox c'est une perte de temps
pendant laquelle nous sommes totalement
déconnecté de nos ordinateurs nos
téléphones portables et des télévisions
et en fait quand je suis entré de mon
voyage en asie et là j'ai décidé de
créer la première agence de voyages
spécialiste de la digital detox en
europe
cette agence elle s'appelle into the
tribe elle a été créée il ya un peu plus
d'un an
et l'année dernière c'est plus de 100
personnes qui sont parties se
déconnecter pendant trois à quatre jours
même certains pour une semaine alors je
travaille avec les particuliers mais
également avec les entreprises qui ont
voulu aider leurs salariés à se
déconnecter le but de ces séjours
c'est de se déconnecter d'internet pour
mieux se reconnecter à la nature à soi
et aux autres et ça a des avantages
évidents sur notre vie et sur notre
moral
en effet en ayant pris les feedbacks des
membres dit tout de tribe j'ai noté
qu'ils étaient moins stressés ils m'ont
raconté qu'ils étaient plus détendus
plus reposé et qu'ils avaient réussi à
profiter à 100% de leur voyage alors agi
seul et hop c'est un premier pas et ça
permet d'avoir un déclic qui nous fait
comprendre que la vie sans internet
c'est aussi cool
mais j'essaie de faire comprendre aux
participants mais ces jours qu'il faut
continuer 7digital détox dans la vie de
tous les jours et là je vous donner
quelques astuces qui vont vous aider à
mieux vous connecter à moins d'être
connecté par exemple lorsque vous avez
un dîner une soirée un déjeuner essayez
de ne pas regarder votre téléphone
donc vous pouvez essayer de couper la 4g
vous pouvez tout simplement mettre votre
téléphone en mode avion ou couper les
notifications mais bref essayer de ne
pas sortir votre téléphone pendant tout
un dîner et vous allez voir que les
résultats sont assez rapides vous avez
beaucoup plus dans l'interaction avec
les autres vous avez beaucoup plus
attentifs à ce qu'ils disent si vous
êtes au restaurant par exemple les 80 de
nos amis n'arrive pas déconnecté et ben
vous fait un petit jeu très simple vous
mettez tous les téléphones au milieu de
la table et vous voulez vous les empiler
comme ça et alors et si l'un qui prend
son téléphone y payent l'addition mais
je vous promets que si vous êtes huit
personnes la femme va prendre son
téléphone après le but c'est aussi
d'améliorer notre sommeil on est trop
dérangé pendant notre sommeil par la
technologie alors des petits conseils
très simple votre téléphone vous le
mettez pas sur votre table de nuit
vous le mettez dans votre salon et à la
place d'acheter un réveil si vous voulez
vraiment laissé sur la table de nuit
vous le mettez en mode avion et vous
verrez que vous allez passer des nuits
beaucoup plus réparatrice vous n'allez
pas être tentée de vous lever le matin
et d'avoir comme premier geste ce regard
ce smartphone et vous allez surtout ne
pas être dérangé pendant toute la durée
de votre nuit donc une nuit réparatrice
donc ce sont mes os de pau après il ya
des efforts à faire aussi en entreprise
vous allez bientôt aller en entreprise
ou créer votre société vous allez voir
que des petits conseils peuvent
transformer vos journées de travail par
exemple éviter le multi tasking essayer
de faire qu'une seule chose à la fois ci
vous trop dérangés par les mails essayer
de les consulter que trois à quatre fois
par jour
en une vingtaine de minutes plutôt que
d'y revenir toutes les 7 minutes toutes
les 10 minutes vous allez voir ça va
vous libérer beaucoup plus de temps
libre pour travailler sur des tâches de
fond pour être plus créatif et au final
qualité de votre travail
sera bien meilleur vous êtes en réunion
bannissez les téléphones une réunion
c'était pour échanger pour discuter pour
présenter un projet sais pas si c'est a
remarqué mais c'est hallucinant de voir
une personne qui a préparé sa
présentation produit sa préparation de
projets est en train de parler devant un
public et certains ont public ne
l'écoutent pas ils sont sur leur
smartphone en train d'écrire des mails
d'une c'est respectueux pour la personne
qui parle mais en plus pour ceux qui
sont en train d'écrire des mails et bah
ils sont pas en train d'écouter et ils
vont pas retenir toutes les informations
importantes
enfin il ya le droit à la déconnexion on
en a beaucoup parlé au début de l'année
2010 est le droit à la déconnexion c'est
un droit qui nous permet au salarié même
aux dirigeants à tout le monde en fait
de pouvoir avoir un vrai temps de repos
le week-end les vacances et les soirées
mais ce droit la déconnexion l'employeur
doit le proposer à ses employés mais
doit le respecter et doit comprendre que
des employés qui sont bien plus reposés
après leurs vacances qui n'ont pas
travaillé pendant les vacances sont bien
plus productif à leur retour et c'est à
vous de saisir ce droit c'est à vous de
stopper vos emails professionnels
pendant vos vacances
bref vous l'avez compris il est
important de moins se connecter de mieux
se connecter pour augmenter votre
bien-être et essayer ces petites
méthodes et vous verrez rapidement que
votre niveau de stress va descendre que
votre niveau de bien-être va monter vous
serez plus créatif plus attentif et plus
concentré donc je vous invite tous à
rejoindre le mouvement de la digital
detox
pour amel et améliorer votre bien être
merci
[Applaudissements]